oh here comes here comes the old
tick tick tick tick tick tick tick tick
tick tick tick i don't know
you [__] the hell you don't for 15
years i've had time oh dad
are you fighting yes
daddy water daddy water
it's okay buddy it's okay only your butt
got wet what the
[__] is wrong with you he almost drowned
as a baby you heartless [__]
i did daddy billy kicked me in the
eye a little jesus christ
[Music]
ah son of a [__] [__] american cars
oh not hamburger assistant again
why can't mom make dinner ask her she's
the one who abandoned her post
and after doing all the lady work i
gotta leave to go do some man work
and is anybody gonna get me flowers and
tell me i'm beautiful
no no one's out there marching for old
frank murphy
he just watches the sands of his
miserable life gather at his feet
while his wife the modern woman throws
on a pantsuit every morning and just
there's my worker bee ah christ sue
can i have a saturday on this long march
to the grave
where i have the house to myself so i
can watch my bowling and take a dump
without lighting a match
stop bottling up your feelings that's
crazy talk this is why women live longer
than men
no it isn't it's because you're nagged
to death with your [__] head
leave it alone sue just tell me [__]
vivian i said hello you look great honey
no no no no colt luger is a man you are
a girl take that off
[__] what where did you hear that
oh right
hey when your mother comes home don't
tell her i use that word what if she
never comes home
dog you little [__] ah [__]
does it ever fail just answer it
god damn it this better be good
he's dead oh oh okay
yeah of course of course yeah who died
my boss ed there was an accident at the
airport
oh my god are you serious they want me
to come in early tomorrow to cover a
shift
sue i think i just got promoted to
management
i think you did too you know what i
think our luck is finally turning around
jesus frank a man is dead yeah but he
was kind of a dick
frank you know if this had happened a
week ago we could have got a bigger tv
frank god i'm trying to sleep then close
your eyes and shut the [__] up
oh let me tell you something you goddamn
son of a [__] i don't need
a goddamn engraved family bible
you see you see what i say every god
damn time i am eating dinner with my
family young man i don't need a 25
bible to teach me about god i almost
bled out in korea all right
i have met god hey
since when do you read it's when you
care since i'm your father and i'll put
you through that [__] wall
move your ass you're gonna be late
they'll be fine just lock em in throw a
can of tuna on the couch and see which
one survived
but i've been up since 5 30 and it's
cold out and i'm tired from my route and
i'm tired from your bitching
what's the point of it all anyway the
point is that's life and life has no
point
you work hard you get ahead you start a
family and the kids don't appreciate you
next thing you know you're old no one
comes around anymore and you're staring
at the wall and one day the neighbors
notice a funny smell and that's when
they figure out the cat's eating your
face so go to school you think you can
put on a pair of slacks and talk to a
grown man like that well do you
this is not how business is done i am a
customer of this store
of standing i bought a radio back here
when there was no tv and you sir were
stealing your dad's balls
why don't you just pay my son what you
owe him
or else what i don't know maybe i'll
just wrap this thing around your [__]
head
i was always taught to keep things to
myself we didn't burden other people
with their problems
it's considered impolite but i don't
know how the hell went bad in the first
place
all i know is everything was great with
us when i had my old job and now i'm
stuck with you people in a dumpy cabin
that wreaks a deer piss and pipe tobacco
and all we have is this cheap watery
peanut butter you gotta stir first
before you put it on the bread where's
the goddamn stepping good he's awful
me you married a father killer
must be nice finding a kid who isn't
wise to your [__] yet
i'm so sorry i kept you fed and clothed
during tough times
oh did you clothe your own child jesus
christ
somebody get him a pulitzer you know you
should smile
more you should walk off a [__] cliff
signed her name on your neck with her
mouth oh yeah
so who's the lucky lady oh she's not a
lady she's a girl at school
you don't know her and if you did that
would be really creepy see that uh
yeah you know the one you went to summer
school with who you know that uh
no i don't know you know i don't
you know your uh little lady friend
there
south of the mediterranean she's not
black if that's what you're worried
about
racist racist though what the [__] i
don't care if she's black white brown
green or purple you freak the [__] out
if she was purple
everybody would it's weird such a dick
i'm not the one calling people racist
it's all day to feed three ungrateful
kids it's not about you
it's about her everyone this is what it
looks like when a man emotionally
abandons
his wife
who was he who who is the guy who dumped
you
and made you this way did he turn back
into a rat after the spell wore off
frank
i said play the party i'm okay with it
i'm being the cool dad now it's all
groovy hey hey we're the monkeys dodge
the drafts
[__] [__] christ we're looking at
a strike here now goddamn pogo will want
me to calm down the union guys while he
shoves another fruit pie down his
[__] cake hole meanwhile my wife is
training around roy town
selling that plastic [__] to pill
popping housewives and i don't get
supper till
hey oh there you are
[Music]
if you don't get her a doctor right now
but for all these other
low-life pieces of [__] then i will
follow you to whatever home for dried up
old hags you live in
slap the cat food out of your mouth grab
you by your camel huff
and put you through that [__] wall
i've been carrying you for three months
i just saved the airline saved your
goddamn job which appears to be nothing
more than eating and you stood by while
i got
fired well [__] you [__] dunbarton then
[__] you
you miserable tub of living [__]
francine
you son of a [__] hey maybe you'd like
to heckle your granddaughter for the
second half of the play for old time's
sake
huh for the last [__] time i didn't
heckle you
yes you did [__] you forgot your
goddamn [__] lines and i was covering
for you with a couple of jokes well i
forgot my lines because my own father
was laughing at me
in front of the entire [__] town you
look like
red skelton's dick ah there it is
there it is just once just [__] once
can you admit what a selfish [__]
[__] you were
who you were always just like your mommy
a whiny [__] who turned on the
waterworks
every time things got tough until you
tough your piece of [__]
mr murphy's take your seats the play is
about to begin